Bitte schön.
Okay.
Ja, ich breite ein paar Sekunden um meine Analympie Spoken Force bereit.
Darf ich vorbereiten?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ja, ich bin bereit. Darf ich anfangen?
Ja, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Umderegid.
Und heute bin ich der Dienstabendarzt auf der Sästation.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen gerne das Erstgespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja.
Es ist ja wichtig, dass jemand nach mir guckt.
Es ist egal, wer das macht.
Hauptsache, es schaut jemand.
Ja, vielen Dank. Nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Ja, ich würde das erst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir auch sofort zu Ihrem Beschwemme.
Okay?
Ja, das ist gut.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Lisa Kraft.
Lisa Kraft.
Ja, Frau Kraft. Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, K, F, T.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,61 m.
Und wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, leider.
Ich wiege 97 kg.
97 kg.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Informations-
Ich weiß, das ist zu viel, aber es ist auch schwer,
etwas runter zu bekommen.
Ja, Frau Kraft.
Was tut Sie heute sonst? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe schon seit Tagen
heftige Kopfschmerzen.
Und jetzt ist heute, gestern Abend hat das angefangen,
dass ich mit einmal nicht mehr richtig gucken konnte.
Ich hatte so Sehstörungen.
Ich hatte das Schlimmerte vor meinen Augen.
Und da habe ich dann doch ein bisschen Panik bekommen.
Ich habe gedacht, ich muss jetzt doch mal heute Morgen
schnell in die Klinik kommen.
Das war mir sehr unheimlich, ja.
Frau Kraft, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen,
uns zu kommen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit gestern Abend
heftige Kopfschmerzen haben.
Nein, die Kopfschmerzen habe ich schon länger.
Ich habe immer mal Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, das ist so vielleicht schon seit ein paar Wochen.
Aber jetzt, dass das so heftig ist
und jetzt hält es eben seit drei Tagen an.
Und ja, die Kopfschmerzen allein nerven schon,
aber jetzt dieses, dass ich nicht mehr gucken kann.
Das macht mich ganz besorgt, ja.
Ich konnte auch nicht selber mit dem Auto hierher kommen.
Also, das wäre gar nicht gegangen.
Mit wem haben Sie jetzt hier gekommen?
Mein Mann hat mich gebracht mit dem Auto.
Okay.
Könnten Sie mir zeigen, wo die Schmerzen genau sind,
im Ganzenkopf oder linksseitiger, linksseitiger?
Eigentlich auf beiden Seiten, ja.
Auf beiden Seiten, ich habe das Gefühl, es hemmert so.
Es klopft, ja.
Ja, ich muss dokumentieren, alles, was Sie erwähnen,
so beide Seite.
Was ein bisschen erleichterung gebracht hat,
ich habe dann eine 600er Ibuprofen genommen
und dann ist es ein klein wenig besser geworden.
Dann konnte ich auch ein bisschen schlafen in der Nacht.
Aber ich kann dann nicht ständig nur Schmerzen haben.
Okay, haben Sie einmal Sie knippen,
haben Sie eine Ibuprofen? Nein, eigentlich jeden Abend eine.
Jeden Abend, okay.
Also, seit es los gegangen ist mit den Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, Sie haben erwähnt, aber ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen.
Könnten Sie mir beschreiben, wo die Schmerzen genau sind?
Also, die sind auf beiden Seiten, also unter der Schädeläcke,
im Kopf und ich habe das Gefühl, es pocht, es klopft da drin, ja.
Vorhänden und kopfend.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, nein, nein, das ist nur im Kopf und da klingt es wie.
Ja, Frau Kraft, wie ich dachte, die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leid und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen entschiebt.
Ich würde vielleicht sagen, so mittendrin, das kann man ja schwer einschätzen,
aber vielleicht am ehesten so bei 5.
Es ist schon so, dass es mich eigentlich so besorgt macht und das nervt.
Wenn Sie immer Kopfschmerzen haben und es wird nicht besser, denn ja.
Okay, haben Sie einen Auslöter bemerkt?
Das kann ich nicht sagen, nein, das fängt mit einmal an und seither geht es nicht weg.
Okay, haben Sie etwas außer diese Ibuprofen ein Name bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ich habe mir jetzt nicht viel gemacht die Tage, ich fühlte mich gar nicht in der Lage dazu,
aber ich hatte dann das Gefühl, wenn ich mich hingelegt habe abends,
dann kann man sich die Schmerzen ein bisschen wegdenken.
Also wenn ich nichts machen musste, war es vielleicht ein klein wenig besser,
aber ich habe überhaupt nicht funktioniert diese Tage.
Ja, okay. Sie meinen in Ruhe verbessert sich die Schmerzen?
Noch mal bitte.
Sie meinen Sie, dass in Ruhe Schmerzen sich verbringt?
Ja, ich denke Ruhe ist es besser erträglich, wenn man nicht arbeiten muss oder irgendwas machen.
Also bei der Arbeit habe ich mich jetzt dann auch krank gemeldet,
weil ich gesagt habe, ich kann so mich überhaupt nicht konzentrieren.
Als was arbeiten Sie?
Ich bin Buchhalterin.
Buchhalterin. Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, gut, bei der Arbeit hat man eigentlich immer Stress, ja.
Ja, Sie haben Recht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, Sie haben erweitert, dass Sie nicht anschauen können, habe ich recht?
Dass ich nicht was kann?
Dass Sie Sehstörungen haben.
Ja, ich habe Sehstörungen, genau, ja, ich kann nicht gut gucken.
Könnten Sie ein bisschen genau beschreiben, was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, es ist so wie früher, wenn der Fernseher kaputt ist, ja,
und man hat nur noch so einen Flimmern auf dem Bildschirm.
So habe ich den Eindruck, es flimmert vor meinen Augen.
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen Sie.
Es flimmert vor den Augen.
Flimmert?
Okay, haben Sie Schwerkeiten beim Laufen oder Schiprieren?
Beim Laufen?
Ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Ich kann nicht bewegen.
Hat Ihr, man bemerkt, dass Ihr Gesicht gelehmt hat oder?
Gelehmt?
Nein, da ist nichts gelehmt.
Nein, nein.
Hatten Sie eine Hebäche werden für Sie?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe eigentlich schon lange,
immer mal Kopfschmerzen, aber dass das so heftig ist
und so andauernd eigentlich nicht.
Also das ist bestimmt schon ein Jahr,
dass ich immer mal so Kopfschmerzattacken habe,
aber dann nehme ich eben Ibuprofen und dann ist es wieder gut.
Aber jetzt wird es halt nicht so richtig besser, ne?
Okay.
Seit einem Jahr, sagen Sie, okay,
haben Sie dagegen Ihr Hausdachs oder eine Neurogien besucht?
Na ja, gut, ich bin ja regelmäßig in hauseärztlicher Behandlung.
Ich habe so einen leichten Diabetes,
wissen Sie, diesen Alterszucker und musste halt immer Tabletten nehmen
und dadurch bin ich eigentlich schon regelmäßig beim Hausadres,
aber der hat dann zu mir gesagt, wenn ich eben Schmerzen habe,
soll ich Ibuprofen nehmen, ne?
Okay.
Würden bei Ihnen eine Kompetentomographie oder MRT-Doc geführt?
Nein.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, Frau Kraft, ich habe Ihre Beschwerden verstanden,
aber möchten Sie, bis auf diese Beschwerden,
ist Ihnen noch etwas Ungewöhnliches aufgefallen?
Möchten Sie etwas insofern?
Nee, das ist das, was mir jetzt im Augenblick gerade notmacht,
und das, was ich hierhergekommen bin, ja.
Ja, okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie zu Hause Ihr Blutdruck gemessen?
Ja, der war tatsächlich hoch.
Also, der war gestern, war der bei 140 zu 80
und heute war der noch deutlich höher,
da war der bei 180 zu 90.
Das ist für mich also schon auch ein bisschen viel eigentlich.
180 zu 90.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Kraft, jetzt möchte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer allgemeinen
Gesellschaft zustande stellen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit hat sich in der letzten Zeit geändert?
Der ist immer gut, leider, ja.
Aber der ist nicht schlecht geworden, nein.
Ja, okay.
Fühlen Sie sich fiebrig?
Fiebrig?
Ja, fiebrig.
Nee, nee, nee, Fieber habe ich bestimmt, also ich fühle mich nicht so,
als ob ich Grippe habe, oder wo ich habe nur diese Wahnsinns-Kopfschmerzen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stilflust oder Nachtweiß?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masalassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, also, das einzige Problem,
ist, dass ich eigentlich jede Nacht einmal auf die Toilette zu sind durch.
Aber sonst habe ich da keine Probleme.
Okay.
Ja, einmal ist normal.
So, Sie haben keine Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Okay.
Ja, bis auf nächste Masalassen können Sie gut anschlafen,
oder durchschlafen?
Ja, jetzt mit den Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen,
aber normalerweise kann ich eigentlich ganz gut schlafen, ja.
Seit wann können Sie nicht gut durchschlafen?
Ja, jetzt seit ich diese Kopfschmerzen habe.
Okay.
Da fällt mir halt das Einschlafenschwer, ne?
Ja.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Erlehmende, Kamente oder Tee ausprobiert?
Zum Einschlafen?
Nein, nein.
Also, wie gesagt, das Ibuprofen habe ich gegen die Kopfschmerzen genommen,
in der Hoffnung, dass ich dann einschlafen kann, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, ich halte das so ziemlich stabil auf hohem Niveau, ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, Frau Kraut, jetzt werde ich eingefragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Schokokrankheit haben.
Ja, halt diesen Alterszucker, ne?
Seit wann leiden Sie an Schokokrankheit?
Ja, das ist schon zehn Jahre.
So ein Jahr.
Ich habe eigentlich gekommen, als ich in die Wechseljahre gekommen bin.
Da hat das angefangen.
Im Wechseljahr.
Ja, ja, ich nehme mit von mir jeden.
Morgen und Abend.
Mit von mir und morgen und abends.
Kennen Sie die Tomsierung?
Ja, das ist mit von mir in 850, was ich da eingebauen habe.
850.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ihr Brutdruck gemessen und zu hoch waren.
Leiden Sie unter Brutdruck?
Ja, das hat man vor fünf Jahren, hat man das festgestellt.
Dann nehme ich halt jeden Morgen Ramipril, so eine Tablette.
Und dann kontrolliere ich das halt hin und wieder.
Okay, kennen Sie Tomsierung von Ramipril?
Das ist Ramipril 5.
Ansonsten leiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nein, das ist das.
Mit dem Brutdruck und mit dieser Zuckerkrankheit.
Und dann hatte ich vor zehn Jahren noch, aber seither habe ich keine Schwierigkeiten mehr.
Hat sich eine geilen OP?
Nein, OP.
Vor zehn Jahren.
War das OP-Komplikation ohne Probleme gelaufen?
Das ist gelaufen zum Glück, ja.
Außer diese Kalanblasenentfernung, wurden Sie operiert?
Nein, sonst hatte ich noch nie eine Operation.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Außer Ibuprofen und diese Metformen und Ramipril nehmen Sie andere Medikamente, Regeln oder Beimedarfe?
Nein, sonst sind das die einzigen Sachen, die ich nehme.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Fragraf sind bei Ihnen allergien sowie unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, also, was ich nicht nehmen darf ist Penicillin.
Da kriege ich so einen juckenden Ausschlag davon.
Penicillin, du kannst diesen Ausschlag.
Es ist etwas anders.
Wie sonst ist nichts bekannt, als dass irgendwas allergien aussieht?
Okay, vielen Dank.
Fragraf, sind Sie voll geimpft?
Was sind geimpft?
Ja, also Sie meinen gegen Corona, da habe ich vier Impfungen bekommen.
Und habe die auch, denke ich, ganz gut alle vertragen.
Und ich habe zwar einmal Corona gehabt, aber nicht so einen schlimmen Verlauf.
Und ja, jetzt, also und sonst die anderen Impfungen als Kind und so,
das ist ja schon alles ewig lange her.
Frau Kraft, sind Sie in der letzten Zeit gereist?
Gereist?
Ja, gereist.
Also nur, so was, was ich die Kinder besucht, aber keine großen Reisen.
Wo haben Sie die Kinder besucht?
Ja, hier in Deutschland.
Ja, Frau Kraft, sind Sie rauchig?
Nee, geraucht habe ich noch nie.
Okay, Sie haben gut gemacht.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Ja, also hin und wieder, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt oder wenn es mal ein gutes Essen gibt,
dann trinke ich schon gerne mein Glas Wein, aber würde eher sagen so,
weil Gelegenheit, ja, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Ja, ein Gewiss Wein.
Okay.
Haben Sie erfahren, mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen, nee, mit Drogen habe ich weiß gut keine Erfahrung.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Sehe ich es so aus?
Nee, also Sport treibe ich wirklich nicht.
Haben Sie zuvor treibt?
Früher, ja, als Kind, als junge Frau habe ich mal Sport gemacht, aber schon ewig nicht mehr.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie die Kinder besucht, sind Sie ja und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Töchter und die wohnen aber natürlich außerhalb,
die sind natürlich schon erwachsen.
Ja, so weit töcht da.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja.
Also, naja, so gesund wie ich, die eine ist auch schwer übergewichtig, muss man sagen, ja.
Entschuldigung, haben Sie gesagt, dass übergewichtig?
Die eine hat auch, die eine ist genauso wie ich, hat die Ordnung übergewicht.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, mein Vater, der ist schon ganz früh gestorben.
Der hat im Bergwerk gearbeitet und hatte dann so eine Lungenerkrankung
und er hatte dann Lungenkrebs.
Lungenkrebs.
Ich bin mir leid auf ihn.
Wie alt war er?
Er ist nur 40 geworden, er ist ganz früh gestorben.
Es tut mir leid, jetzt sieht es.
Leidet Ihr Vater außer Lungenkrebs andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, dafür war der viel zu jung, um noch andere Erkrankungen zu haben.
Also ich nicht wüsste nicht.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Ihre Mutter noch am Leben ist?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, ja, ja.
Die ist eigentlich relativ gesund, die hat ein bisschen Probleme mit ihren Gelenken.
Ja, also das vermut man, dass sie Arthrose hat, aber ja, in dem Alter ja auch kein Wunder.
Hüftartus oder Kine?
Alle großen Gelenketun der Wehe, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Gehschwister?
Ich habe zwei Schwestern, ja.
Ich hatte zwei Schwestern und die eine ist früh auch früh gestorben.
Die hatte ältere Schwester, die hatte Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt, ja, es tut mir leid.
Ist andere Schwester gesund?
Die andere ist so, wie ich weiß, ist sie gesund, ja.
Ja, okay.
Ja, Frau Kraft, ich möchte zu Ihrem Beschweden zurückkommen.
Haben Sie Gleichwertigkeitstörung?
Was habe ich für Störung?
Gleich, gleich, gleich, Gleichgewicht?
Gleichgewichtstörung, ja.
Gleichgewichtstörung, nein, nein, nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, also übel ist mir so höchstens so von den Tabletten,
weil ich nicht, weil die Kopfschmerzen auch so heftig sind,
aber nicht so richtig übergeben musste ich mich nicht.
Ja, Frau Kraft, meinerseits habe ich eine wichtige Information
und gestern, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen,
dass ich wissen sollte?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt, also ich wüsste nicht,
dass ich noch viel in Künfte habe.
Ja, Frau Kraft, entschuldigen Sie, ich habe einige Fragen vergessen zu stellen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Ihr Hausarzt regelmäßig besucht,
Besuchen Sie auch Ihr Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, diese Krebsvorsorge mache ich halt schon regelmäßig, ja.
Ja, wann war Ihr letzter Besorgeuntersuchung?
Das war im Ende des letzten Jahres, also ein halbes Jahr her.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie vor zehn Jahren in Mechsel Jahren...
Ja, genau, mit 50.
Was sind die Probleme dagegen?
Die Probleme, die man halt so hat, in der Zeit habe ich dann nachzeit ein bisschen geschwitzt,
aber ansonsten war das nicht so schlimm.
Ja, okay, vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank, Frau Kraft.
Ja, so haben Sie Fragen, kann ich antworten?
Ja, also ich will natürlich wissen, wo kommen diese Kopfschmerzen her
und was kann man dagegen tun und vor allem diese komischen Sehstörungen
jetzt zwischendurch sind sie ein bisschen besser, aber man fühlt sich so unsicher,
wenn man nicht gut gucken kann.
Und ich möchte natürlich wissen, wo das herkommt.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, habe ich die Informationen gestern,
aber alle Massnahmen sind wichtig für uns
und ich muss zuerst die körperlich untersuchen.
Dann würde ich einige Massnahmen durchführen.
Was für Massnahmen?
Ja, ich würde bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ja, klar.
Ja, und gegebenenfalls würde ich eine komputerte Fomografie oder ein Martit führen
um eine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen oder den Differenzialdiagnosen
um zu schließen.
Okay, und tut das weh?
Nein, es tut nicht weh, aber die Komputertefomografie
ist eine Strellingebene der Verfahren.
Okay, da hat man Strellingbelastung.
Ja, aber wenn ich Blut abnehme, tut es ein bisschen weh.
Ja, das kenne ich ja vom Hausarzt auch.
Nach dieser Massnahme können wir genau besprechen.
Alles klar.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Sie haben uns entschieden, uns zu kommen.
Zu Ihnen zu kommen.
Okay.
Und wir, unser bestes Mann.
Alles klar.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, klar.
Danke schön.
Nein, weiblich.
Erst mal.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Ja, ich bin, ich hache, gönn, guten Abend.
Haben Sie bewusstlos sein verloren?
Ob ich das bewusst sein verloren habe?
Nein, nein, überhaupt nicht.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühle?
Wo soll ich ein Taubheitsgefühl haben?
Nein, ich habe, also, was meinen Sie?
Wo soll ein Taubheitsgefühl haben?
Krebeln, zum Beispiel.
Krebeln in dem Finger oder...
Nee, so was habe ich nicht.
Super.
Und haben Sie aura?
Fühlen Sie aura?
Was ist eine aura?
Ja.
Aura bedeutet, könnte man verstehen,
vielleicht meine Kopfschmerzen ein bisschen drucken
und die anderen gefühlen.
Die Kopfschmerzen haben plötzlich angefangen.
Okay, okay.
Tinnitus und haben Sie Tinnitus?
Tinnitus habe ich nicht, nee.
Und haben Sie Albrecht?
Nee, also, mir war jetzt ein bisschen schlecht von den,
glaube ich, von den Ibuprofenen
und hatte ich so, aber ich musste mich nicht übergeben
und also, mir war nicht richtig doll schlecht, nein.
Sie hat gesagt, habe ich viele seit Tagen
heftige Kopfschmerzen.
Deswegen, können Sie schon hausarzt diese Probleme besuchen
oder...?
Nein, ich habe ja gedacht, das geht wieder weg
und als es heute Morgen, das mit diesen Seest,
das Abend mit den Seestörungen, das kam,
da habe ich halt gesagt, ich komme gleich ins Krankenhaus,
weil mir das so unheimlich war.
Und Sie hat gesagt, ich rauche nicht,
aber haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe nie geraucht.
Und Ihre Schwester wegen akkutser Milkainfarktys gestorben,
und dann waren Sie, wie alt war sie?
Wie alt war sie, ja.
Ja, Sie waren Mitte 60.
Mitte 60.
Okay, okay.
Danke schön.
Genug, noch andere Frage.
Frau Kraft, fühlen Sie sich häufig Licht
oder Lärmemfindlungen bei Ihre Residviere in den Kopfschmerzen?
Nee, bisher hatte ich das nicht,
dass ich diese, also Lärm, würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen,
und Licht, das kannte ich bisher auch noch nicht,
dass ich da nicht gut gucken konnte, ja.
Das ist jetzt zum ersten Mal gekommen.
Okay, danke schön.
Bitte schön, Gülschan.
Bitte schön.
Danke schön.
Ah, sorry.
Hallo, Gülschan.
Hallo, besteht in Ihrem Gesichtsfeld
dunkel oder verschattete Bereiche?
Nein, nein, das,
das ist ein,
ich finde, dass ich eben kein klares Bild habe,
sondern so ein flimmer Bild, ne?
Okay.
Keine Einschränkungen des Gesichtsfeldes.
Sehen Sie doppelt?
Doppelt sehe ich auch nicht, nein.
Okay.
Noch eine Frage, Kollegen.
Diese Fall ist bekannt.
Es ist ein neuer Dusseldorfer, ne?
Haben Sie nächste Zeit vermehrt und durst diese Frage?
Das steht ja witzigerweise nicht.
Hat mich selber auch gewundert,
dass die Frage nicht, also dass das gar nicht erwähnt wurde.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat sie mehr Durst, ja.
Ja, und Nackensteifigkeit.
Ach so, ja, nee, das hat sie nicht.
Trauma.
Trauma, ja, gut, ja, das stimmt, gute Idee.
Nein, ich habe mir nicht den Kopf gestoßen
und bin irgendwo gegen gelausen
oder hatte auch keinen Autounfall und kein Fahrradunfall, gar nichts, nein.
Kollegen hat gefragt, dass sie beim Wasserassen Problem haben.
Sie haben, nein.
Genau, ich habe nur gesagt, ich muss nachts einmal auf die Toilette.
Könnten Sie wieder denken?
Bitte was?
Geräuscht, Wasserassen geräuscht.
Sie meinen Geruch?
Ja, Geruch, Geruch.
Sie meinen nicht Geräuscht, sondern Geruch, ja, das selbe.
Geruch.
Ja, also es ist mir nicht aufgefallen, das ist besonders.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Ich denke auch, ja, das waren sehr viele Fragen.
Ja, könnten wir als als Geschiebte.
Mein Doktor hat ja auch schon sehr viel gefragt, ja.
Ja, ja.
Könnten wir als als Geschiebte amTang?
Von mir aus, ja.
Eine Kollegin haben die verstopft in der Nase.
Ich habe die Nase tatsächlich im Augenblick,
deswegen kribbelt meine Nase so ein bisschen,
aber die Patientin hat das nicht.
Können wir loslegen?
Ja.
Umrutsch?
Gut, Frau Weisling, ich habe heute ein neues Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte, haben Sie es seitwürdig?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, der Patientin heißt Lisa Kraft.
Frau Kraft ist 60 Jahre alt, 1 Meter,
6 cm, 61 g und wiegt 97 kg.
Sie ist verheiratet und lebt mit, lebt mit, lebt mit ihrer Mann.
Sie arbeitet als Buchhaterin und sie habe Stress bei der Arbeit.
Sie hat uns seit gestern Abend, 5 Jahren,
heftig, heftig, pohende, klopfen,
hat ihr geholfen, aber seit 3 Tagen verschlimmert sich die Kopfschmerzen
und seit gestern habe sie Sehschmurrung gehabt.
Was für Sehschmurrung?
Ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen, aber sie hat erwähnt,
dass sie in ihrem Augengeflimmer traut.
Geflimmert, ja.
Ja, Geflimmert.
Diplopie wurde bei der Patientin verneint.
Sie hat erwähnt, dass ihr Augengeflimmert hat.
Sie hat über 600 mg Übeprofen eingehoben,
aber sie hat nicht geholfen.
Die Schmerzintestät liege bei 5 von 10 in Schmerzskala.
5 von 10 auf Schmerzskala.
Sie hat keine Auslöser, aber im Ruch verbesert sich verbesert.
Sie würden dich verbesern.
Sie verbesert sich verbesern.
Ja, die Fragen nach Facialparalysie,
Emesis, Tinnitus, Trauma,
wurden von der Patientin verneint.
Sie hat zu den Vegetativen Beschwerden gehören,
in Somni wegen Schmerz, einmal pro Nöktuvi.
Sie hat gemeint, dass sie Nausea kommen können.
Sie hat seit 10 Jahren die Geheimtestmellitus.
Sie hat seit 5 Jahren die Arterielehypertonie.
Sie hat mit der Form von 850 mg Geheimtestmellitus
2 Mal pro Tag.
Sie hat mit der Form von 550 mg Geheimtestmellitus.
Vor 10 Jahren hat eine Kolesistik-Tomy OP
bei der Patientin durchgeführt.
Sie hat auf Penicillin allergisch geabstellt.
Darauf reagiert sie mit Purgutus und Exantem.
Ihr Impfstatus ist postständig.
Auch gegen Corona 3 Mal ist sie geimpft.
Sie hat einmal Corona erlitten.
Sie hat in Deutschland ihre Kinder.
Sie ist keine Raucherin.
Alkoholkonsum liegt bei Englischwein.
Sie hat keine Erfährung mit Drogen.
Sie hat keinen Sport.
Sie hat auch nicht Sport gemacht.
Sie hat nicht Sport gemacht.
Sie hat keine Erfährung mit Drogen.
Sie hat zwei Schwester.
Eine Schwester ist an die Mucartinfarktus gestorben.
Andere ist sein gesund.
Sie hat zwei Schwester.
Eine ist übergewicht.
Eine genokologische Anämpfung ist unaufwählig.
Sie besucht ihre Frau und Arzt.
Sie besucht ihre Frau.
Apoplexy, Hintumo, Migraine und ja, ich habe diese Differenzialdiagnose.
Um meine Differenzialdiagnose zu bestätigen und um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen und
die Differenzialdiagnose auszuschließen, würde ich der Patientin zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, worauf achten Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Ja, ich würde zuerst neurologische Untersuchung und ich würde...
Ja, was machen Sie da zum Beispiel?
Ja, zum Beispiel, ich würde Kraft, ja, ich würde gleich, gleichwertig...
Gleichsinnigkeit, ja, Gleichsinnigkeit oder Symmetrie, ne? Darum geht es, ne?
Ja, Symmetrie und Asymmetrie überprüfen.
Ja, ich würde auch überprüfen, ob eine Attaxi gibt und Musikkeit gibt.
Ja, ich würde auch, ja, der Patientin hat Fibafirma, aber ich würde auch nach Strafigkeit überprüfen, ob es Musikkeit gibt.
Ja, und ich würde auch sehen, auch Augen, ob Augen überprüfen, ob eine Anisokorie gibt oder ob die Lichtreflex gibt.
Ja, okay. Ja, gut, was machen Sie noch mit der Patientin?
Ja, nach der Untersuchung würde ich Blut abnehmen, besonders Blutbild- und Entzündungsparameter.
Und, was noch?
Ja, ich würde auch entschlügen.
Beim Blut, was untersuchen Sie noch mit, wichtig?
Beim Blut, meines Erfolges. Ja, Blutbild- und Entzündungsparameter.
Und Entzündungsparameter, und was noch?
Ja, dann würde ich, ja, würde ich überprüfen, ob eine Venöse, Venöse-Trombos gibt.
Ja, spricht ja aber eigentlich nicht so viel dafür.
Na gut, aber Dedimere machen Sie mit und was machen Sie noch?
Ja, dann würde ich eine Computertamographie und MRT.
Gucken Sie noch mal nach dem Blut.
Blut, ja, ich habe…
Die Patientin ist Diabetikerin.
Entschuldigen Sie, ja, ich habe auch Blutzuckerbestätigen überprüfen.
Bestimmt, ja, den musst du bestimmen.
Genau.
Blutzucker und die…
Und Habi A und C vielleicht oder so, ne?
Ja, Habi A und C und ja, die Natrium- und Chlorbestimmen wegen sehr warmem Blick.
Ja, dann…
Gut, und dann wollen Sie Bild geben an die Patientin, generalmente?
Entschuldigung?
Danach wollen Sie eine Bildgebung machen.
Ja, dann würde ich eine Computertomographie oder MRT dafür…
Mit welcher Fragestellung?
Entschuldigung?
Mit welcher Fragestellung MRT oder CT?
Ja, ich würde fragen, ob sie gegen Kontrastmittel allergisch ist.
Ja, aber was soll denn da überprüft werden?
Ja, ich würde fragen, ob die Nierenmerte in normalen Grenzen sind.
Ja, damit man Kontrastmittel geben kann?
Ja, okay.
Was wollen Sie denn rausfinden mit dem CT oder MRT?
Was ist die Fragestellung?
Blutung oder…
Ja, ne, ja, warmem CT würde ich eine Blutung bestätigen oder ausschließen.
Ja, beim MRT würde ich eine Apoplex…
Apoplex…
Und auch eine Tumor?
Ja, Tumor.
Mit Kontrastmittel.
Könnte man ausschließen, ne?
Muss ausschließen.
Okay, gut.
Ja, und haben Sie sonst noch irgendwelche Untersuchungen vor mit der Patientin?
Entschuldigung, könnte ich Sie wiederholen.
Planen Sie noch weiter auf Kontrastil?
Ja, wenn ich eine Verdacht auf Menigitis würde, ich eine Lycoanalyse…
Oh, ja.
Das würden Sie aber nur machen, wenn der Verdacht auf die Menigitis sich erhärtn würde, ne?
Ja, Menigitis oder eine Lycoanalyse haben.
Ah, ja, okay.
Gut.
Ja, dann untersuchen Sie die Patientin bitte und halten mich auf dem Laufenden über die Ergebnisse.
Vielen Dank.
Okay, gut.
Ja, also, ja, genau.
Vielen Dank, Sie haben mit.
Ja, und das ist das eine, ne?
Weil sie ja auch von deutlich höheren Bedruckwerden berichtet hat, trotz…
Ah, Glaukom hat noch jemand die Idee, okay?
Ja.
Also, Sie sind sehr bei der Tia, ne?
Ja, die Patientin ist 60 Jahre alt und sie hat beide Seite kopische Meso-…
Beide Seiten, genau.
Das klassische bei der Migräne ist ja diese Halbseitigkeit, ne?
Ja, die Halbseitigkeit.
Und da wäre dann der Gesichtsausfall, den die eine Kollegin erfragt hat.
Das wäre so typisch, ne?
Ja, gut.
Ja, also die Anamnese fand ich sehr schön.
Das war vollständig.
War sprachlich auf, also überwiegend, sehr, sehr gut.
Manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen Verständigungsprobleme gehabt.
Magst vielleicht technische Qualität irgendwie dahinterstecken, ja?
Dass wir uns nicht so gut verstanden haben.
Aber grundlegend war das sehr gute Verständigung.
Und im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch sind mir eigentlich nur zwei Sachen aufgefallen.
Und zwar die drei Sachen.
Einmal ganz am Anfang haben sie gesagt, die Patientin hat seit gestern die Kopfschmerzen.
Aber hinterher haben sie das ja nochmal korrigiert.
Da haben sie seit drei Tagen, hat sie die heftigen Kopfschmerzen.
Und seit gestern hat sie diese Sehstörung, ne?
Und ja, diese Sehstörung ist hier für mich beschrieben worden mit Flimmern vor den Augen.
Ist erwähnt als Fotopsy.
Also sie hatten eine Sehstörung.
Aber das konnten sie sich, also damit konnten sie nicht viel anfangen mit der Beschreibung.
Das war für sie nicht bildhaft.
Ich habe versucht es zu sagen, wie früher, wenn ein Fernseher kaputt war.
Wenn der Fernseher kaputt ist und keinen Empfang hat, dann macht er ja nur so ein Kribbelbild.
Und so etwas hat sie vor den Augen.
Es flimmert, also vor den Augen sehr Sehstörungen.
Gut, ja, gut.
Also das war die, die eine Geschichte.
Dann hat sie ja gesagt, die, die Ibuprofen hätten ihr ein bisschen geholfen.
Ja, sie und da haben die gesagt, hat ihr nichts geholfen.
Also ein bisschen Hilfe hatte sie durch die Ibup.
Aber eben die Schmerzen waren trotzdem drei Tage lang durchgehend.
Ja, und der Vater ist mit 40 gestorben, nicht mit 70.
Also das war, glaube ich, nur ein Hörfehler.
Sie haben hier 40 geschrieben.
Sie haben 40 geschrieben, aber 70 gesagt.
Ja, okay.
Also sie ist sehr, sehr jung schon gestorben.
Jawohl.
So, und die Mutter hatte, hat vermutlich Arthose alle Gelenke.
Genau.
Ja, also nach den, nach den Unterlagen, die ich habe,
ist der Entgleiste über Donus.
Einige Schichten, die sehr naheliegend ist.
Aber tatsächlich ist es ein Entgleister Diabetes.
Ja, die und da haben sie auch nicht sehr viel nachgefragt.
Das hat die Patientin auch nicht erzählt.
Sie ist zwar regelmäßig bei ihrem Hausast und sie kontrolliert
eigentlich regelmäßig, aber ihr sind die Teststreifen ausgegangen.
Ja, also sie hat jetzt länger nicht kontrolliert und ja,
ist irgendwie, wenn man gefragt hätte, ja kontrollieren sie das regelmäßig
oder gehen sie regelmäßig zum Hausast,
wäre man da vielleicht hingekommen.
Aber sie hat also länger nicht kontrolliert, weil sie keine Teststreifen hat.
Und ja, tatsächlich ist die Diagnose Entgleister Diabetes.
Gut, aber ich denke mal, sie haben sich sehr,
sehr schön geschlagen und haben eine sehr gute Vorstellung gemacht.
Also ich denke, sie müssen für ihre Prüfung keine Sorge haben.